>> MCKINNON N IN THE GAME AT
LEAST THREE SHOTS ON GOAL FOR C.
>> I DON'T KNOW MANY TEAM THATZ
DO IT BETTER
FRUSTRATED THEM.
THE POWER PLAY SHOWING A FEW
SIGNS OF THE NEWEST AV IS
KNOCKED DOWN BY
AUSTIN STRAND CATCHES THERE ON
THE RIGHT
JACKET.
GRUNDSTROM UP TO, AND A QUICK R.
THE FIRST HAND WAS OKAY, THE
SECONDHAND WASAS STAND-UP.
>> E GLOVE OF QUICK THE PUCK ANE
ONE STEP TO UP.E.  LEESH WANTED
TO GO TO THE SET PLAY.
YOU IS TO READ Y ACTS FASTER THU
WANT TO GO. KEMPER.
MOORE TIES CENTER.DS UP LINE.
SHOULD I I
LEMIEUX, THE SAME SYSTEM,
BUT YOUR MESSAGE AND
COMMUNICATION HAS THE SAME
WORDS.
>> THE BOYS WERE MCKINNON.
IN THAT FIRSTZI,
WHAT A RECOVERY TO GET POSITION
OUTLET.
KINGS MAKE CAREER FIGHTING
MAJORS, FIVE THIS SEASON.
>> THE
LOOSE PUCK.
>> CAN'T SAY ENOUGH JOHNSON.
>> SPENCE OUT THERE AACES
KUEMPER.
IT WAS FACED 35 PLUS IN EACH OF
HIS LAST THREE START SAVE REBOUE
FEED NEK NEK.
>> OF COURSE
A LITTLE BIT MORE STRENGTH AND .
BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS SPECIAL
TEAMS.
KINGS ZERO FOR TWO NEED THERE AA
WAY TO GET BODIES AND PUCKS IN
NET A WAVE THERE.
THAT'S OFF GOING AT IT ALL GAME
AND THAT LITTLE PUSH CREATED
ENOUGHGH
ANOTHER MISTAKE I MACED GAMES
AND YOU'RE THINKING THE KINGS
ABLE TO GET TWO AGAINST FLORI